[Music]
this is a big time for you your show
debuts tomorrow and you just had a son I
just be kind of father two months ago
yeah yeah that's that's nicely women
applauding that I actually got the girl
who played the prostitute and the pilot
pregnant is that true that's the girl
around
no no a woman in the pilot who plays a
prostitute you guys I know I left it in
once and then and now we have a child
and we couldn't be happier and the
child's great and and in a way I love
him and but my girlfriend actually loves
him like she actually loves this baby
doesn't do anything yes she gave birth
to a child and she loves me no he
doesn't talk or anything like she this
is what goes through a woman's mind when
they hold a child for the first I was
like I'm gonna love you forever no one's
gonna ever love you more than I love you
this is what goes through a man's head
when he holds his child for the first
time I bet not let this die if this
thing dies people I don't know we're
gonna be cranky yet he's basically a
[ __ ] he he I have to put these I have
to put mittens on his hands so he
doesn't claw his eyes out in the middle
of the night cities what nine ten months
old he's two months old two months old
yeah oh yeah well then he's really got a
lot of problems yeah yeah animals just
fall out and then they go hunting
what my child if I don't hold him right
his head might fall off so let me get
this straight as I find this fascinating
the actress who plays a prostitute you
guys have you guys hook up and there's a
baby so what happens later on when your
your child says hi I have to look him in
the eye and say when I Met Your Mother I
employed her as a prostitute I'm not
gonna lie to him I gotta be honest yes
we're very happy and the child we have a
little baby is called Hank and it's all
working out great
although I'm like I'm never gonna give
him a television I give him TV because I
don't want a little bastard writing on
the walls like these French people come
on like how good the TV must have been
in French yeah I wouldn't have one
either yeah you're watching the cross on
Channel
now let's talk about your your show your
show has some heart I mean you you can
be an edgy comedian but your show has
hard the whole show wrote rotates right
you guys know DJ calls and DJ Qualls
plays a character with muscular
dystrophy on the show and it comes from
a true life story where I took a friend
with muscular dystrophy to a brothel
before he died it was like a make-a-wish
Foundation but for adults there's a true
story and your friend asked you before I
go would you please this is something
that it was he asked me he said he said
I won't be actually the guy in real life
is still alive and kicking I'm still
alive yeah he asked me and me and his
brother we took him out to a brothel in
Melbourne we've changed that to Vegas
for the story and to this day his
parents don't actually know it was him
because we covered it up so well the
story like I must know a lot of people
with muscular dystrophy because I
changed their name and if parents don't
know well if they watch this they do
I took your son to a brothel
[Music]
I'm coming yeah hello no other people
watching show in Australia